way in the columbia and northwards on
the pacific coast
japan was our next neighbor across the
way
only the placid sea the pacific between
us
then as it had been for 200 years or
more it was
by its own laws barred to the world
except and that with very close
restrictions to the chinese
and the dutch it was death to any other
foreigner or even to any japanese who
had been from any cause
absent in any foreign land even
shipwrecked mariners unless fortuitously
speedily relieved by some
foreign warship of sufficient force had
to pay the penalty of death sooner
or later a utopia of the east
an easter island empire lathed and
sustained by lone
teeming seas to us on its opposite shore
gazing searchingly into the far far
offing it was
ever an object of intense curiosity
what of such people what of their manner
of life what of their unrivaled wealth
with its gleam of gold and things most
precious i resolved within myself to
personally
solve the mystery if possible at any
cost of effort
yay life itself
my plan was to present myself as a
castaway and with all seeming confidence
without seeming to caught it to rely on
their humanity
[Music]
the present is the story of it
whaling was easy in the japan sea the
fish were so numerous that we had no
occasion to chase them with our ship
we had nothing to do but to lower our
boats harpoon them
and bring them alongside for stripping
the ship being now nearly full
i asked the captain to go back towards
japan
where on the island of timoshi of its
northern coast
i intended to land with much reluctance
he consented according to our bargain
and so
against the strong and earnest
reministrations of the captain and crew
i stepped into my boat taking with me my
box of books and stationery
a few clothes but i had no chart
my comrades refused to unloose the knot
which bound me to them
one of them offered to accompany me i
refused him
a sailor's feelings are ever warm and
true
myself with averted face had to cut the
rope by which i hung to all of them
with the quivering god bless you mack
they paid me along and as they thought i
last
had you thus to my family and friends
i was for a while as one dead
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
there are lots of very old things in
japan the people
the hotels and most of all the royal
family
the kosciutzu is the oldest continuous
monarchy in the world
and so a great recommendation from
magellan's collection this week
is banzai tenno long live the emperor
from the series asia's monarchies which
tries to unravel this ancient
institution
and how it survived world war ii into
the modern day
magellan tv have supported this channel
for more than a year
and they are a great choice if you like
documentaries they have more than 3
000 works to choose from and now you can
take advantage of an exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even if you've joined magellan before
elapsed you can simply click on the link
in the description to claim your
discounted membership today
thanks
at dawn the next morning i saw smoke on
the island
and men launched a boat like a rather
large skiff and rode it towards me
when about a hundred yards from me they
hove up and began to
salaam me throwing out their arms palms
up
bowing stroking their great beards and
uttering a
guttural sound in respectful salutation
as indicated by their look and manner
when near enough i accosted them with a
how do you do
with a salute with the right arm they
seemed
to take it in complement in response on
landing i was greeted by
about a hundred men women and children
on approaching the large
house we were met by a japanese whose
exterior
denoted consequence the front part of
his head was shaved
and the hair was gathered into a top or
queue
which projected slightly over the
forehead his dress consisted of a long
cotton clerical looking gown in entering
the house which was
of one story with paper windows we had
to walk about
20 feet on bare ground the priest then
busied himself in spreading out mats
stirring the fire
and giving orders he by signs
requested me to put off my sandals i for
the first time then perceived
that he had none on placing mine in a
particular spot he gave me to understand
that i would always find them there
after a short interval my host invited
me to partake over a past
which he kindly provided it consisted of
boiled rice
some good fish ginger preserved
shellfish and a variety of pickles
before and during the meal my host
several times offered me a bottle of
something which he called
grog yes on smelling it
for being then a temperance man i did
not taste it
i found it very like whiskey the liquor
is a distillation from rice
called by the japanese saki the name
grog yes puzzled me but on inquiry
afterwards
i learned that it arose from the fact of
the crew of the lawrence
who had been in that quarter answering
grog
yes fetch it on when it was offered to
them
i may hear mention that when in china on
my way to japan
i was told that one of the men of this
same lawrence
was killed by the japanese for
attempting to escape while a captive
with them i never knew the particulars
of the case
it did not frighten me
after breakfast i took a short walk out
of doors the only freedom i had in japan
and that under close watch on my return
i found that my kind host had provided
me with a bed
and a good mosquito bar not having slept
the night before
i turned in and now did so most
comfortably
[Music]
on the following day to oyakata chiefs
or overseers of the island visited me
they took a minute inventory of
everything brought ashore
everything seemed to excite their
curiosity especially my books and
letters
they looked intensely at every article
first one way
then another and then would talk about
it last of all they opened my keg of
provisions
being religiously abstainers from meat
they were horror-struck in finding the
beef and pork
after a long consultation they examined
the pieces with a long
fork the people i was now among were not
japanese proper
but i knows who are a tributary to the
former
the i knows so far as i saw and could
learn
have no government of their own but seem
to be simply scattered individualities
in families without any obstacle
communal organization
though there seems to have been such
from the uniformity of their manner of
life and subordination to their
distinctive customs and religion and to
their
chief so-called but how so constituted
or being
i cannot say i've been asked as to my
idea of the origin and racial features
of these i knows
i have never read up especially on the
subject of human races
though i am especially familiar with the
inhabitants natives and
other of the west and northwest coasts
of north america
from san francisco to sitka amongst
these
especially the hydras and bella cooler
coast indians of british columbia
i remark a striking similarity of
physical type
with my sturdy friends of yeso but in
disposition they differ much
[Music]
at length we anchored in the outer
harbour of nagasaki
a great number of the inhabitants
officials i presume came on board
among them sheree takatian sama
one of the five men who assisted the
governor in the government of the
district of nagasaki
he and another of note sat in japanese
fashion
in the middle of the cabin with two
pale-faced secretaries by them
with writing materials books of
apparently english or european binding
and a large book like an atlas sat also
was an interpreter
a very old gentleman with a benign
expression of countenance
rising a little asked me in a very kind
tone
what my name was i told him and he
repeated it to
share i the latter then asked me through
mariama another interpreter where i was
born
of this young man a few special words
are called for
he was by far the most intelligent
person i met in japan
he had a pale cast of thought piercing
black eyes which seemed to search into
the very soul
and read its every emotion he spoke
english pretty fluently and even
grammatically
he was my daily companion a lovable one
ever afterwards during my sojourn in
japan
i asked him whether he moriyama had ever
been out of the country
to which he replied in the negative he
told me that he had a large
library and also that he was studying
latin and french
nagasaki is a town or city rather of i
should say about ten thousand houses
the houses though small compared to ours
of our city
seemed on the whole to be of a better
class than anything i had seen elsewhere
in the country
murayama came in and told me that in
half an hour i would appear before the
governor
to answer questions that would be put to
me he told me not to be afraid
to take courage that he would interpret
for me and that he would be sworn
he instructed me also that before seeing
the governor
i should see an image on a metal plate
at the four door
these were his words and further that
this image was the devil of japan
and that i must put my foot on it i told
him i would do so because i did not
believe in images
very good very good said he and then
retired
in entering i looked for the plate with
image in the four door
of morayama and there i in plan
saw it it appeared to me to be a bronze
plate round about six inches in diameter
flat on the ground with something
delineated on it which
stooping to examine i took to be the
virgin and child
told to put my foot on it being a
protestant i unhesitatingly did so
pointing to the door he said you will
see the governor enter by that door
but you must not look at him but bow low
i then heard a low rustling sound
approaching towards us
and as if by a given signal everyone
fell flat on their face
behind me close and all about was
soldiers at arms
the governor entered moriyama repeated
his injunction
to bow low still angry i didn't
i koto to no man it required no effort
to refrain i just would not do it
curious to read my fate at the hands of
his excellency
i looked at him fearlessly but
respectfully full in the face
so did he me i had just quickly before
that
looked around and saw everyone even the
soldiers flat on their faces
the hands being placed on the ground and
the forehead resting on them
they all remained in this position for
quite a time say 10 or 15 seconds which
in dead silence the governor and i
stared
at each other at length rising from his
sitting position
slowly on his knees and stretching forth
his arms
the governor addressed me a few words
deep toned and low
which though i did not understand them i
took from his manner and look
not to be unfriendly afterwards for i
could not at the time i asked moriyama
what he said
he answered he said you must have
a big heart
during nearly all my confinement and
nearly daily
moriyama and others were my pupils there
was 14 of them
the habit was to read english to me one
at a time
my duty was to correct their
pronunciation and as best as i could in
japanese explain meaning
construction etc it was difficult to
make them catch some of our sounds
especially the consonants and some of
the combinations particularly were
impracticable to them
for instance they cannot pronounce
except very imperfectly
the letter l they pronounce it r
so that they rendered my name renardo
mcdonald with a strong burr of the r
they also had a habit of adding an i or
o at the end after a consonant
my place of residence though really a
prison for i had no liberty beyond the
bars of my cage
was the resort of quite a variety of
people men of all sorts
students officers priests and people in
general of the respectable classes
except women came to stare at me as a
natural curiosity
the only exception as to women was in
the case of one of my guards
the captain of them he asked me for my
consent to bring his wife and daughter
and three of their females to see me of
course i
gave it for i was anxious also to see
how their women looked
they came entering the guard room and
squatting there like men
i invited them if they wish to see me to
enter my apartment
the lion's den they all did so
giggling i cannot say that they were
beautiful
nor on the other hand that they were
ugly their general expression of
countenance was that of smiling
good-natured and
artlessness calculated to make a
favorable impression
being nothing of a ladies man poor at
small talk
i had no conversation with them merely
in
lion raw addressing them on their entry
and departure with a few words
japanese and compliment
missing the captain shortly afterwards
for we were
close friends i inquired about him and
was informed at his head
had been chopped off that was how they
expressed it
for breaking the law forbidding what he
had done in bringing women to my prison
if so which i could scarcely believe the
law seemed to me to be a very harsh one
in course of conversation with my guards
and visitors i caught it certain
sailor terms used by them which i
suspected they must have picked up from
british or american sailors about the
place
they used without telling me where they
got them to ask the meaning of these
terms
for by this time i could speak a sort of
pidgin japanese or at least
had the reputation for it many of these
terms i could not literally translate as
they were simply
sailor objections meaningless and
innocent generally such as
shiver me timbers etc my imprisonment
though close allowed me daily
communication with people
many sorts who from curiosity came to
see me
the japanese i would observe are
naturally chatty
always in a vein of good humor in this
respect i was
in rapport with them in look facial
features etc i was not unlike them my
sea life and rather dark complexion
moreover giving me their general color
a healthy bronze i never had a cross
word with any of them
and i think i passed rather as a
favorite amongst them
eliciting everyone anon the compliment
of the governor
as to my heart naturally they are brave
i
should say utterly fearless of death
their instincts markedly military
i believe they would suffer annihilation
rather than surrender in defense of
their country
unconquered unconquerable that is their
proud position
enjoying a well-guarded liberty in their
social life and a perfect toleration of
creed
except as to that form of christian
faith known as roman catholic
banned for reasons of state over 200
years ago they had nothing to complain
of
under that mask of placidity which they
presented i could see the inner working
of aspirations for a higher life
among the nations of the earth i
perceived this more particularly in
murayama
and some of the younger of my pupils all
grown men
with minds of keenest search acute
enough to pierce the veil of their old
traditional life which to them was as
the rotting shroud
of a dead past they i would say are
naturally the cleverest people i know of
i say cleverest not in the sense of
deceit but in its highest and purest
meaning
all they require is light from without
on this head i could say much as the
result of my experience in reflections
but refrain and confine myself to my
narrative
at last about the end of april i heard
for the first time in the country
cannon shots i asked whether the new
governor had arrived
with a lear they said yes at the same
time looking at each other
at this time i had several or all of the
interpreters with me
i did not know at the time what made
them crowd in them
this one when they had all gone came up
to the bars of my cage and told me that
a foreign ship had arrived
and that the guns were fired as a signal
for troops from the interior
the foreign ship which had just arrived
was the american corvette
the prebble of 18 guns in command
of captain glynn while i was in the shed
13 american sea men were brought in they
had on their ordinary sail address
i had on my best japanese dress very
plain and respectable
they appeared very pale and thin we all
appeared at the same time before the
governors
the governor through interpreter then
told us of the arrival of the ship and
that they had
after consultation decided on allowing
us to depart
by her so on april 26 1849
after 10 months of shijon in japan
including about seven months of teaching
english to a class of 14 government
interpreters
i was as stated delivered over to the
american authorities
on march 31 1854 the first
convention first in all history i
believe was made by japan
with a foreign power that was with the
united states of america
it was soon followed by others in like
tenor with other foreign powers
now not only in commerce but in general
international committee
japan is open to the world
it now stands practically abreast of the
most advanced nationalities of europe
in political status
you